cloud computing has completely changed
our world it allows us to store and
access our data from anywhere making our
life more convenient plus we can now
work with people from all over the world
without a hitch all thanks to cloud
computing so Cloud projects are a big
part of this change they help us learn
and try out new things with Cloud
technology which is really important
it's like a playground for Learning and
solving real world problems so whether
you are making an intelligent Gadget
creating a website or even predicting
the weather cloud computing does play an
important role so here we are with
another video on top 10 cloud computing
projects in 20124 whether you are a
beginner an intermediate level cloud
Enthusiast or an advanced level cloud
expert we have got you covered here so
hey everyone and you are already
watching simply before starting with the
top 10 cloud computing projects what
2024 subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily also
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn also do check
out the cloud architect Masters program
by simply learn this program will help
you build your AWS Microsoft aure and
Google Cloud platform expertise from the
ground you'll learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable fall tolerant
applications and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS and Azure
Cloud expert this program will give you
an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
asure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC asure app services gcp and much more
you'll acquire the Knowledge and Skills
for passing Cloud architect
certification such as AWS architect and
Azure architect candidates with one plus
year of work experience are preferred to
enroll in this program by simply Lear so
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
moving on to the top 10 cloud computing
projects we have divided this video into
three parts the first part is for
beginners moving on to the first project
for beginners we have a cloud-based file
storage in this project you will create
a simple cloud-based file storage system
similar to a Dropbox or a Google Drive
users can upload download and manage
files stored in the cloud the part to
create this project will start by
choosing a cloud storage service select
a cloud storage service provider like
awss 3 Google Cloud Storage or Azure
blob storage the next step is creating
an account sign up for an account with
the chosen cloud provider if you don't
already have one the next step is to set
up a bucket or a container create a
storage bucket or container to store
your files the next step is to develop a
web interface create a web based
interface for users to interact with
your storage system you can use HTML CSS
and JavaScript for this the next step is
to implement file upload and download
add functionality for users to upload
and download files to or from their
storage bucket using the cloud providers
SDK or API the next step is user
authentication Implement user
authentication to secure access to files
you can use services like Firebase
authentication or build one of your own
the next step is testing and deployment
test your file storage system locally
and once satisfied deploy it to the
cloud make it publicly accessible if
needed the key learning points of this
project is you will learn the basics of
cloud storage Services file uploading
and downloading and user authentication
moving on to project number two we have
a website hosting service this project
involves setting up an essential website
on a cloud platform like AWS Azure or
Google Cloud you will deploy a static or
dynamic website and make it accessible
to to users worldwide let's move on to
the path to create this project the
first step is to select a cloud hosting
service choose a cloud hosting platform
like Amazon web services Azure or Google
Cloud the next step is to design your
website create the content and design
for your website you can use HTML CSS
and JavaScript for static websites or
web Frameworks for dynamic ones then
register a domain name purchase a domain
name from a domain register for example
GoDaddy name chap ET the next step is to
configure DNS configure the DNS setting
to point to your Cloud hosting servers
IP address the next step is to set up a
virtual Server create a virtual server
instance on your chosen Cloud platform
for example AWS ec2 Azure VM and Google
compute engine the next step is to
install web server software install and
configure web server software like
Apache on your virtual server and the
last step is to upload website files
upload your website files to the server
and then you are done with the project
the key learning points of this project
you will learn how to configure a web
server you will deploy web applications
and manage domain names and finally you
will ensure High availability the next
project we have for beginners is a
cloud-based calculator create a simple
web-based calculator application and
deploy it on a cloud platform like heru
users can perform basic calculations
using this calculator let's talk about
the path to create this project you will
start by selecting a cloud platform
choose a cloud platform like Haku AWS or
Azure for deployment then develop the
calculator create a simple web based
calculator you can use HTML CSS and
JavaScript for this then set up a
development environment install
necessary development tools and
libraries on your local machine then
move ahead with Version Control use
Version Control Systems like G to manage
your project then create a cloud account
sign sign up for an account with your
chosen Cloud platform then comes the
deployment part deploy your calculator
application to the cloud platform of
your choice for Heroku this might
involve pushing your code to a g
repository and then comes the testing
part ensure that the calculator
functions correctly on the Cloud Server
let's talk about the key learning points
of this project you'll gain experience
in setting up Cloud Server environments
deploying web applications and
understanding server client interactions
moving on to inter mediate level
projects these projects are for people
with decent knowledge of cloud computing
Basics the first project we have in this
category is an iot data analytics
project build a system that collects
data from iot devices sensors smart
devices Etc and stores it in Cloud
databases for example AWS Dynamo DB or
Azure Cosmos database Implement
analytics to gain insights from the
collected data let's talk about the path
to create this project the first first
step is iot device setup set up iot
devices or sensors to collect data then
choose a cloud database select a cloud
database service for example AWS Dynamo
database aszure Cosmos database for data
storage then comes the data inje part
right code to send data from iot devices
to the cloud database then comes data
analytics Implement data analytics tools
or scripts to analyze the collected data
then comes data visualization create
visualizations to present insight from
the data using tools like AWS quick site
or data visualization libraries and then
the last part is monitoring and scaling
Implement monitoring and scaling
mechanisms to handle increased data
volumes so let's talk about the key
learning points of this project you will
explore iot data inje Cloud database
management data analytics and of course
data visualization moving on to the next
project we have a video streaming
service so you will create a video
streaming service where users can upload
and stream videos from the cloud
Implement features like video encoding
content delivery and user authentication
let's talk about the path to create this
project you will start by selecting
cloud services choose cloud services for
video storage for example AWS S3 for
encoding you can choose AWS elastic
transcoder and for Content delivery you
can choose AWS Cloud front the next step
is to design the application plan the
architecture of your video streaming
platform in including user interfaces
for uploading and streaming the next
step is user authentication Implement
user authentication using services like
AWS Cognito then comes the video
uploading part allow users to upload
videos to the cloud storage and then
comes the video encoding Implement video
encoding to create different quality
versions of uploaded videos then comes
the content delivery use a Content
delivery Network or CDN to distribute
videos efficiently to the users and the
last step is testing and and scalability
Test video streaming and ensure its
scales to handle concurrent users and
varing network conditions let's talk
about the key learning points for this
project you will learn about video
processing content delivery networks and
secure user access control moving on to
the next project we have cloud-based
e-commerce website build an e-commerce
platform hosted on cloud develop
features like product listing shopping
carts and secure Payment Processing
let's talk about the path to create this
project you'll start by selecting Cloud
platform choose a cloud platform for
example AWS or Azure to host your
e-commerce application then comes the
e-commerce framework choose an
e-commerce framework for example
woocommerce or Shopify or build a custom
solution then comes the product listings
part at product listings and
descriptions with images then comes the
shopping cart Implement a shopping card
functionality for users to add products
then comes the secure Payment Processing
setup reur Payment Processing using
payment gateways like stripe or PayPal
then comes the user authentication part
Implement user authentication for
customer accounts and finally the
testing and security thoroughly test
your e-commerce website ensuring it's
secure and capable of handling
transactions what are the key points of
this project you will gain experience in
building scalable web applications
handling online transactions securely
and managing customer data talking about
advanced level cloud Computing projects
for advanced level cloud computing
projects you should Master Cloud
infrastructure and cloud services the
first advanced level project we have for
today is machine learning with Cloud
develop a machine learning model and
deploy It On A Cloud Server for scalable
processing this project involves working
with large data sets and real-time data
analysis the first step is machine
learning model develop a machine
learning model using libraries like
tflow or CET learn then comes the data
preparation part prepare and clean the
data for training and testing then
choose a cloud machine learning service
select a cloud machine learning service
for example AWS Sage maker Google AI
platform and Etc then comes the model
deployment part deploy a machine
learning model on the cloud platform and
finally the scalability ensure the model
can handle real-time predictions and
scale as needed let's talk about the key
learning points of this project you will
delve into machine learning cloud-based
data processing and model deployment the
next project we have in this list is the
cloud-based virtual desktop create a
system that allows users to access
virtualized desktop environments hosted
on the cloud this project focuses on
remote desktop Solutions talking about
the path to create this project you
should start by selecting cloud service
choose a cloud service for virtual
desktop for example Amazon workspace
Windows Virtual desktop or Azure then
comes the configuration part configure
virtual desktop instances with desired
specification user management create and
manage user accounts for accessing
virtual desktops security Implement
security measures for data protection
during remote desktop access then comes
the access control part set up Access
Control policies to restrict user
permissions and lastly testing test the
remote desktop access from different
devices and locations talking about the
key learning points of this project
you'll learn about virtualization remote
desktop Technologies and user Management
in a cloud-based context moving on to
the Third advanced level cloud project
we have a cloud gaming service build a
cloud-based gaming service similar to
Google stadia this project involves GPU
virtualization low latency streaming and
multiplayer game server management
talking about the path to create this
project you should start by selecting
Cloud infrastructure choose a cloud
infrastructure you can either choose AWS
or Azure for hosting game servers then
comes the game server setup set up Game
servers for hosting games then comes the
low lat latency streaming Implement clo
latency streaming Technologies for
gameplay then comes the multiplayer
support add multiplayer support for
users to play together then comes the
user management create user accounts and
manage players profiles and finally
comes load balancing Implement load
balancing to handle increased player
loads talking about the key learning
points of this project you will explore
cloud-based gaming infrastructure server
management and real-time multiplayer
networking moving on to the last cloud
computing project we have a healthcare
data management system develop a
cloud-based system for storing and
managing healthcare related data such as
patient records ensure compliance with
healthcare industry standards for
example
hiaa talking about the path to create
this project you should start by
ensuring compliance with healthcare
industry standards Hippa compliance
understand and adir to hipa compliance
regulations Cloud platform selection
choose a HIPAA compliant cloud platform
for example AWS Healthcare apis and
Azure for healthcare then comes the data
storage part create a secure cloud-based
data storage system for healthcare
records then comes the access control
Implement strict access controls and
encryption for data security then comes
the audit trials maintain audit trials
for data access and modifications and
then at last comes the user training
ensure staff are trained on hipa
compliance and data handling protocols
talking about the key learning point of
this project you will gain expertise in
Cloud security data privacy and
compliance while addressing real world
Healthcare data challenges these
projects provide a progressive learning
path allowing individuals to start with
basic Cloud Concepts and gradually
advance to more complex and impactful
cloud computing applications each
project offers valuable experience and
skills that can be applied to real life
scenarios and career development in the
cloud computing field so that's a wrap
on this video on top 10 cloud computing
project for 2024 if you feel that we
have missed out on any particular
project or if you have any doubt related
to any of the topics we have covered in
this video then please feel free to drop
them down in the comment section below
and a team of experts will be happy to
help you as soon as possible so thank
you so much for being here today we'll
see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skill skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here